we have the inequality two thirds is
greater than negative four y
minus eight and one third now the first
thing i want to do here just because
mixed numbers bother me they're actually
hard to deal with mathematically they're
easy to think about oh it's a little bit
more than eight let's convert this to a
improper fraction so eight and one-third
is equal to the denominator is going to
be three three times eight is 24 plus
one is 25.
so this thing over here is the same
thing as 25 over 3. let me just rewrite
the whole thing so it's two-thirds is
greater than
negative 4y
minus
minus 25
minus 25 over 3. now the next thing i
want to do just because dealing with
fractions are a bit of a pain is
multiply both sides of this inequality
by some quantity that'll eliminate the
fractions and the easiest one i can
think of is multiply both sides by three
that'll get rid of the threes in the
denominator
so let's multiply both sides of this
equation by three that's the left-hand
side and then i'm going to multiply the
right-hand side
three i'll put in parentheses like that
and
well one point that i want to point out
is
that i did not have to swap the
inequality sign because i multiplied
both sides by a positive number if the 3
was a negative number if i multiplied
both sides by negative 3 or negative 1
or negative whatever i would have had to
swap the inequality sign anyway let's
simplify this so the left-hand side we
have three times two-thirds which is
just two
two is greater than and we can
distribute this three three times
negative four y is negative 12 y and
then three times negative 25 over 3 is
just negative
25.
now we want to get all of our constant
terms on one side of the inequality and
all of our variable terms the only
variable here is y on the other side the
y is already sitting here so let's guess
this 25 on the other side of the
inequality and we can do that by adding
25 to both sides of this equation
so let's add
adding 25 and the left-hand side 2 plus
25 is 27 and we're get 27 is greater
than
the right-hand side of the inequality is
negative 12y
negative 12y and the negative 25 plus 25
those cancel out that was the whole
point so we're left with 27 is greater
than negative 12 y
now to isolate the y we can multiply or
i think you can either multiply both
sides by negative 1 12 or you could say
let's just divide both sides by negative
12. now because i'm multiplying or
dividing by a negative number here i'm
going to need to swap the inequality so
let me write this if i divide both sides
of this equation by negative 12 then it
becomes 27 over negative 12
is less than i'm swapping the inequality
let me do this in a different color is
less than
is less than negative 12 y over negative
12. notice when i divide both sides of
the inequality by a negative number i
swap the inequality i swap the greater
than becomes a less than when it was
positive i could i didn't have to swap
it so 27 divided by negative 12 well
they're both divisible by three so we're
going to get if we do the numerator and
the denominator by three we get negative
nine
negative nine over four
is less than these cancel out
y so y is greater than negative
nine-fourths or negative nine-fourths is
less than y and if you wanted to write
that let me write this so our answer is
y is
greater than negative nine-fourths i
just swapped the order you can say
negative 9 4 is less than y or if you
want to visualize that a little bit
better 9 4 is 2 and a 4th so we could
also say y is greater than negative 2
and 1 4 if we want to put it as a mixed
number and if we wanted to graph it on
the number line
let me draw a number line right here
real simple one
maybe this is zero
negative two is right over let's say
negative one negative two
then say negative 3 is right there
negative 2 and 1 4 is going to be right
here and it's greater than so we're not
going to include that in the solution
set so we're going to make an open
circle right there
and everything larger than that is a
valid y it's a y that will satisfy
the inequality